que la regarder ce qu'on m'a donné la
fin regardez une étiquette et marquer
destinataire et réal code postal il n'y
a rien entre les deux frères kété la
sonnette
il faut que je connais les deux fils là
pour que ça sonne c'est comment on
reçoit des avis dans nos boîtes aux
lettres alors qu'on est chez nous ça a
brassé une chose qu'on me dit souvent
tout le temps quand je mets vidéo type
ok tu te dis ça nous avons essayé de
placer ce policier un maximum parce que
c'est parce que le livre qui sont comme
ça et c'est vrai qu'à la tête
c'est une vérité après il ya des bons et
mauvais partout bat vraiment manière de
penser et que là je fais livrer mais
quand je rentre chez moi je suis client
pour moi si je commande des choses est
[Musique]
derrière ce prénom
on s'est pas déplacé
quelqu'un qui a posé une journée qui
attend son colis donc c'est vraiment
nécessaire pour tout lui vraiment mais
la cloche chez elle à l'intérieur et à
rien de partir et tu n'as pas c'est
tellement on va demander aux fumeurs
vidéo a été normal j'ai pas il ya un
jour il ya une seule vidéo qui a attiré
le monde où j'avais un collier a livré
en fait mais c'était une maison ou en
face était en droit il n'y avait pas de
maison c'est en chantier avaient doit
livrer un collier la quijano 110 pardon
à 110 rue des bons lyall 108 1
et voilà pour arriver aux 110 j'arrive
au 110 là je me rends compte qu'il n'y a
plus de maison
voilà y'a plus rien il ya un trou là là
là ils sont 12 me lie un trou là vous
abusez je sais que je suis un livre de
qualité sur qu'est-ce que je fais les
jette le coller dans le trou c'est quoi
mais il ya plus de maisons gap une boîte
et les terriens et j'ai mis cette vidéo
comme satan tik tok et je me réveille un
matin je vois les notifications et tous
les yeux sont mort de rire ils
s'abonnent et où on veut d'autres vidéos
on en fait encore n'ont pas encore fait
à l'emploi même là son numéro tu
reprends la plaie on pense pas sauf si
elle est là
mais tu y as est plus populaire auprès
des publics
en fait il est négligé ce mets tes
preuves et négligé moi les gens quand je
redis que ça se fera livreur ça arrive
directement avec les histoires de vie de
passage déposés et stores de voyage de
colis ou c'est un métier facile et que
dans ton camion alors c'est pas le cas
il ya une fois j'ai sonné chez un client
est et il a commencé à crier importe
qu'ils soient nés plusieurs fois et tout
est gelé fait comprendre au mieux que je
sonne que bien il passa dans la boîte
est quoi il continua critères sa porte
et tous et manqué de respect et du coup
bah écoute moi je suis parti et j'ai
fait un avis de passage et même marqué
dessus absence de respect et de la gemmi
des vidéos comme sa sortie toile que les
gens y rigole mbissao web et à raison
avant tout
et ce terroir de qualité on va dire oui
dans le principe les lectures emploi
c'est tout ouais second succès ok c'est
tout à la semaine dernière le roi je la
connais mes doigts l'ambition du maure
exemples de maisons mais comme j'ai
reconnaît à son nom et la leçon à des
clients comme ça des fois la chance je
le reconnais tu vois la reconnaissance
dont 1 en or manas a eu ses sages et en
colère vous livrer chez vous oui je le
vois régulièrement parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup de commandes
oui les deux très agréable et puis j'ai
jamais eu aucun souci
aucun si on nous dit vous serez livrés
chaque jour entre 8h et 13h vous êtes
obligés de passer entre 8h et 13h pour
être leader et précis au moins appeler
le client le prévenir qu'il aurait du
retard au mans le contacter on peut
toujours s'arranger mais pour moi ce
n'est acquis la claque combien de colis
à livrer aujourd'hui 195 195 livres
combien de temps après c'est jusqu'à on
va dire maximum 17 heures en fait ce qui
arrive au dépôt avant avant 19 heures
bon après y'a des fois il propose un peu
parce que depuis ces histoires de
confinement et où il ya vraiment
beaucoup de commandes puis hier
recommande de mieux payés c'est ça
puis on dit c'est ça une journée c'est
combien à peu près une journée après une
journée c'est à peu près on va dire ce
sont deux euros par l'art samedi
seulement normalement qui fait du stand
up c'est ça je fais du stand up d'où mon
surnom antique toxique du stand off
ça demande pas trop la scène là ça peut
voir que tellement au point et j'ai
vraiment hâte que toro que je puisse
enfin venez raconter toutes mes galères
de biberons sur scène quoi bon il est
14h et sidya a terminé sa tournée de
livraison
tu as livré combien de colis en france
95 55 ans et ça en six heures voire six
heures de temps entre qu'ils vont encore
ppr ccca moyenne pour un livreur de
qualité supérieure c'est la moyenne
c'est le minimum en hauteur et la tire
entre à l'agencé ces retours pour faire
leur tour c'est ça ou du conte regard
avec la coupe à la maison
[Musique]